it's database how about the next
question operating systems
and memory and microprocessors
and the internet if you went out and
played golf
and every drive went in the hole you'd
give up the game wouldn't be interesting
i tried to talk to a lot of my friends
that what is internet nobody say ah this
thing never work
this thing never exists wanna be happy
build a life not just a business
[Music]
life
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how
billionaires think and get some success
advice from the top
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be passionate with larry ellison
my objection to cloud computing is the
fact that everyone
this is you know cloud computing is not
only the future of computing eddie
it is the present and the entire past of
computing is all cloud
i mean salesforce.com has been around
for more than a decade
and so is netsuite you know uh next
week's been around longer than
salesforce
and it's people are saying well that's
cloud computing
uh you know google's now cloud computing
everyone's cloud computing
my objection to cloud computing was
everyone simply looks around
oh like yeah like i've always been doing
cloud computing
you know it's like yeah like 10 years
ago but cloud's computing
the term is only four years old yeah
like yeah but i you know
like everything is cla in the cloud now
you know um
and i know my objection is the absurdity
the absurdity you don't like that no no
it's not that i don't like the idea of
what is i mean it's this nonsense
uh i mean the guy said oh it's in the
cloud well what is that
then you say are we dead oh yeah we're
dead if there's no hardware or software
in the cloud we are so screwed
but it's not water vapor all it is is a
computer attached to a network what are
you talking about
i mean what do you think what do you
think google runs on i'll ask you what
anybody did they run on water vapor
i mean cloud they have
and memory and microprocessors
and the internet and all of a sudden
it's
none of that it's the cloud what are you
talking about
now so the vcs i love the vcs oh we only
fun is that cloud
oh yeah oh whoa whoa microsoft word
change internet to cloud mass change
give it back to these nitwits on
sandhill road
i i rule number two
persevere with jack ma when i went back
to china in 1995 with an
idea of the internet was very strange
china was not connected to the internet
so i tried to talk to a lot of my
friends that what is internet nobody say
ah this thing never work
this thing never exists um
because it's true because nobody but
people even say jack is
alive because he's trying to steal money
from people
telling us there is the internet so when
i go to
when i go to the china red company
registration office
i said i want to register company called
hanzo
hope internet company
the guy looked at me and say this is the
english dictionary tell me there's no
there's no word called the internet
why you want a registered company called
the internet
so i cannot register name a company name
but i
in 1995 in
later august china was connected the
internet
i was number seven person connected to
the in china internet
in order to prove i was not a lie
i invited my friend who is a tv man
take the tv camera they all stay in my
home
and we they just tried to take the
picture i
i died from hangzhou to shanghai
shanghai to america to connect the
internet
it took us three hours and a half to
download the first
front of the page at that time there is
no netscape called the mosaic
oh so ever i have to make like a hundred
stars to keep my journalists friends to
stay
and wait because to prove that i'm not
telling a lie
rule number three pursue interesting
ideas with warren buffett
mr buffett in the past you invested in
china south korea and israel
and recently you partnered with 3g
capital and joshua lemon
from brazil over for the heinz deal does
this mean are you tempted to venture
into the brazil market next
i didn't get the question you did the
hinds deal
the question is are you gonna invest in
brazil next oh uh
i don't know where i'm gonna invest next
that's what that's what makes my job
interesting i mean
uh i'm i'm i'm not kidding i mean if you
went out
and played golf and every drive went in
the hole
you'd give up the game wouldn't be
interesting i mean what's interesting is
when you get in the rough and you have
to come out and a few things like that
so
i i love the fact that i don't know what
i'm going to do next you mentioned the
israel investment
in 2006 in the fall
i got a letter from a fellow and i never
heard of him
and i never heard of the company he was
talking about but he said my name is
eton wardheimer
and i want to tell you a little about my
company iscar the letter was a page and
a half long
and he said if he sold the company the
family sold the company the only company
they wanted to sell it to was berkshire
hathaway
and if i was interested they'd be glad
to come over from israel and explain it
to me and it was a
it just jumped off the page that this
was an interesting idea so i
emailed them and they came over very
shortly and and we bought the business
we we handed them
four billion dollars for 80 of a company
where i'd never seen it or anything
etan kept saying you got to come over to
israel and see the plants and everything
you won't believe how wonderful they are
and i said eitan i don't go to council
bluffs iowa you know i mean
i am doing fine in omaha and uh
he said no you know you got to see it i
said no no i don't i i said
we can make a deal without seeing it he
said well if you buy if you buy the
company will you come and see it
i said if we buy the company i'll come
so we bought the company
and i went over there and it's true i've
never seen plants like this it was the
greatest operation i've ever seen
and etan said to me he said you know
that's why i want you to come over to
see these things i said listen
if i'd come and see them i'd have paid
more money so
so it uh we
we have a wonderful partnership with the
people in israel but i don't know
tomorrow
uh our partnership with the people in
brazil with georgie paolo lemon and his
associates
they are sensational people i got to
know george apollo when i was on the
port of gillette with him
and the opportunity to buy into a
wonderful business
like heinz and to be partners and they
do
they they'll do all the heavy lifting
they run the place uh
with georgie pollon associates i mean
it's just
it's a it's a great opportunity for us
and i don't know what the opportunity
will be tomorrow
with george apollo is last december uh
i was going out to boulder colorado
where he had a group that met
and he said i think i've got an idea
might interest you when i get out there
so i went out there and
and uh and as we came back on the plane
he
explained what he was thinking about in
terms of heinz and i said
count me in and uh and i will tell you
one other thing which is
quite impressive about him after i said
that and
went a little a little further on the
thing he sent me a
one-page governance description of how
it
would work between the two of us and he
sent me a very brief description of
what he thought would be a fair deal for
both of us i didn't have to change a
word
i mean those are the kind of people you
like to associate with rule number four
take responsibility with grant cardone i
know a year ago
the last time i was on this interview i
think i just started working out
every day and my body was hurting all
the time i was in pain constantly
you didn't want to do it you were
struggling dude my ankles hurt my knees
hurt my back hurt my
like like i had constant pain in my body
why'd you keep doing it doing what
working out
no that that that's no that i wasn't
working before you started working my
body was
in pain i wasn't using my body i didn't
use it and it started to abandon me
like i wasn't paying attention to it you
know and it's like okay dude
you know you don't want to pay attention
to me i'm going to make you feel maybe i
don't pay attention to you
you know or maybe i'll make you pay
attention to me yeah and then i got i
went to a pt
uh three days a week that really didn't
do anything
and i said you know what i need to take
responsibility for this if i want to fix
something
that that that's the code of my life do
you want to fix something
take responsibility yeah do you take
responsibility don't give it over to the
physical therapist the masseuse i was
trying the masseuse the masseuse never
helped me
i needed to put muscle on my bones
so i i hired a guy named anthony he came
i said you come to the you come to my
place every day
same time every day here's the money
here take the money
here's the schedule i'm never going to
miss a day wow
and he travels with you two or no no no
this was in the first year
got it and um you know it's been
14 months i have almost zero pain in my
body
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve right there
let's go man if you guys don't know evan
follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five search for interesting
experiences with jesse itzler
you'll see something be curious be
interested and do more than just the
you know the casual hey it's nice to
meet you it is i mean if i
if i find someone that's inspiring or an
event or something
i try to introduce he she or it to my
life
and that's part of just my own personal
development you know i'd learn better
through experience than through books
i like to be challenged and i love
interesting people
i like people that are think differently
that act differently that's what
attracts me
that's just what makes me feel like i'm
getting the most out of life
you know and that is i'm on the constant
search for that
because i'm very aware of my own
mortality you know i'm 50 years old
i'm turning 50 and the average american
lives to be 78
and if that were the case and i was
average that means i got 28 years left
and that dictates well who do i want to
spend that time with and what do i want
to do
and that's a driving you know it's like
on repeat in my head
so to answer your question you know
that's that's sort of
what makes me tick rule number six
appreciate little things with elon musk
i'm just saying that you know you want
to take a moment to appreciate
things in life and the sensations um
food's incredible uh and
like there's just so many good things
that you can experience some of them
cost nothing
really um you know have a walk in nature
or
uh just a nice meal and it's like wow
that's pretty great
you know and uh we should take a moment
to
appreciate these these uh little things
the big things
the things that move your heart i think
that's probably the meaning of life
as close definition as i can think and
rule number seven the last one before
very special bonus clip is learn
new skills with jeff bezos the question
is always why not stick to the knitting
so and my point of view on sticking to
the knitting is that
it's not the right thing for most
businesses to be that focused
it's true that you hone skills in a
business you learn to be really good at
a few things
and you do want to extend out from those
skills but your customer needs
change slowly over time and you have to
learn new skills
on behalf of your customers so basically
our customer we had a bunch of readers
as customers people who love to read and
they were they didn't know it
our customers they weren't asking
directly but basically they were saying
to us
you're going to have to learn a new
skill you're going to have to stretch
and learn how to manufacture hardware so
that you can continue to serve me 10
years from now
that's what our customers are telling us
and and that's good if businesses
you know try new things and stretch
their muscles and
and and and put themselves in
uncomfortable situations i think one of
the reasons that
businesses stick to the knitting is
because it's way more comfortable
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're going to enjoy but before
that it's time for the question of the
day
i want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you just get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
got to take action
but when you get motivated and then you
create a specific
plan of action for when and how you're
going to do it
your number jumps from 35 to 91 percent
chance of following through
and when you commit to somebody else
like posting down here in the comments
below that number jumps to 95 percent
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down the comments below so you
can follow through and i can celebrate
you
in the early days i mean as an
entrepreneur you're every department
so i was the before and after butt model
literally
i took a picture of my own butt took it
to kinko's got it laminated
with and without spanx on stood in the
stores and i'm like
hey look what this can do for you um i
was i was like the packer and shipper i
was the head of sales i was everything
and
you learn very quickly what you're good
at and what you're not good at and what
you enjoy and what you don't enjoy and
there's usually a correlation between
the two
and so i often say as soon as you can
afford to hire your weaknesses
and a few years into spanx it was
abundantly clear that the lane that i
needed to stay in was inventing
selling promoting spanx actually is
never advertised
spanx is 18 years old and the first time
we've ever even
sampled an ad was to uh in 16.
and so i was sort of the the
advertisement and
and me being out in the field talking
about the product and sharing the story
of the why why
we're making this why it's better was a
big part of the formula
and i needed someone to be in the
company day-to-day running
the daily operations
if you want another amazing video into
the minds of how billionaires think
check it out right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe
and i'll see you there we don't love
this product but we think
others will love it you know that's not
really how it works
if you don't love it don't expect others
will either your relationship with time
is such a key component
[Music]